bonjour pour notre dernière gentes dames
badass de l'été j'ai choisi de vous
parler d'une personne qui n'est pas
resté célèbre pour sa haute naissance
mais pour son oeuvre artistique et
scientifique
d'où le chapeau anna-maria sibilla
mérian qu'on va tout de suite appelé ana
maria pour aller plus vite et les à
francfort en 1647
son père meurt alors qu'elle n'a que
trois ans mais elle apprend le dessin la
peinture et la gravure auprès de son
beau père jacob marelle dès sa plus
jeune enfance très jeunes aussi elle
s'intéresse aux insectes et en capture
pour les dessiner je me suis dans ma
jeunesse employés à la recherche des
insectes
j'ai d'abord commencé avec les vers à
soie dans ma ville natale de francfort
sur le main
j'ai ensuite établi que à partir des
autres chenille se développer beaucoup
de beaux papillons de nuit ou papillons
de jour comme à partir des vers à soie
se lamente reina à recueillir toutes les
chenilles que je pouvais trouver pour
observer leur transformation
à 18 ans elle épouse le peintre johann
andreas graf et part s'installer à
nuremberg avec leur fille à partir de là
anna maria s'intéresse plus
spécifiquement aux papillons et à leur
cycle de vie
à l'époque on n'avait pas encore trop
compris le système de la chenille
chrysalide papillon qu'on croyait encore
à la théorie de la génération spontanée
une idée d'aristote qui explique que
certains animaux pouvaient apparaître à
partir d'objets inanimés tels que de la
boue de la moisissure et c'est tout ça
par magie par forcément ana maria se
demande toutefois comment on peut passer
d'une chenille à un papillon et elle
décide des croquis de chrysalide des
plantes sur lesquelles on les trouve et
des parasites qu'on trouve sur les
cocons à 28 ans elle fait paraître le
nouveau livre des fleurs un recueil de
croquis son deuxième livre s'appelle la
chenille merveilleuse transformation est
étrange nourriture floral dans lequel
elle présente les différents stades de
développement des différentes espèces de
papillons avec les plantes que mangent
les chenilles adéquate dans ses travaux
elle cherche aussi à trouver une espèce
qui pourrait remplacer le ver à soie
qu'on n'arrive pas à faire vivre en
europe donc il ya quand même une petite
idée commerciale derrière elle se sépare
de son mari en 1685 et divorces
officiellement en 1690 donc ce pas
exactement pourquoi
à partir de là elle vit à amsterdam avec
ses filles et continue de se consacrer à
ses passions
elle possède des collections d'insectes
et de coquillages de coraux etc
gagne sa vie en réalisant des
illustrations pour le compte d'autres
auteurs et en 1699 à l'âge de 52 ans
elle décide de partir en expédition au
surinam
elle compte aussi emmener l'une de ses
filles le but de l'expédition med
étudier la faune et la flore de ce pays
et plus précisément les papillons les
voyages à caractère scientifique sont
encore rares à l'époque elle obtient une
bourse de la ville d'amsterdam
elles vont aussi une partie de ses
travaux et de ses collections et enfin
elle lance une souscription 1 croûte
funding coiffe sur le livre qu'elle
comparaître après son voyage un gros
aspect négatif de son voyage elle
travaille surtout à partir de son jardin
à paramaribo et emploi pour ses
recherches et ses expéditions des
esclaves dont elle ne cite pas les noms
de ces travaux en 1700 elle est obligée
de rentrer au pays bas parce qu'elle a
attrapé le paludisme pendant son voyage
mais avec assez de croquis et d'insectes
pour publier son metamorphosis inseec
thorium souris nhamtchio c'est sa plus
grosse oeuvre même si elle ne se vend
pas très bien et elle est encore une
fois obligé de vendre une partie de ses
croquis de ses peintures et de donner
des cours de peinture pour pouvoir
continuer à vivre
alors que par ailleurs elle était déjà
assez reconnue en tant qu'artiste et
naturaliste elle meurt finalement en
1717 à l'âge de 70 ans
son livre est réédité plusieurs fois au
cours du xviiie siècle et montre
l'apport d'anna maria dans le domaine du
naturalisme à l'époque on s'intéressait
assez peu aux papillons à cause du
phénomène de génération spontanée dont
je parlais et qui rendait ses bêtes très
impopulaire est la même mauvaise
réputation on les appelait des bêtes du
diable le seul point négatif qui fait
que d'autres naturalistes de l'époque
les vite c'est qu'elle écrivait en
allemand alors qu'à l'époque la langue
officielle des sciences était encore le
latin mais au moins ça permet une
meilleure diffusion des sciences
alors pourquoi figure-t-elle parmi les
gens tenaces badass déjà parce que c'est
une femme naturaliste c'était très rare
à l'époque et ensuite parce que c'est la
première femme à avoir voyagé pour ses
travaux au 19e siècle on trouve des
femmes qui effectuent des voyages mais
le plus souvent il s'agit de voyages
poursuivre leurs maris et les assister
dans leurs travaux
la son mari ça faisait longtemps qu'elle
l'avait quitté
à l'époque certains scientifiques comme
luan fredrik brag bac considérer mm
qu'il était dangereux pour une femme de
voyager vers l'équateur
parce que la chaleur risquez de
déclencher leurs menstruations et de les
tuer logique puisque ceux ci était le
dernier épisode de l'été j'espère que ça
vous a plu
je vais sûrement reproduire l'expérience
l'année prochaine si je fais pas
quelques petits épisodes de temps en
temps entre deux parce que j'ai encore
plein de femmes dont j'ai envie de
parler en attendant je vous souhaite une
bonne rentrée et on se retrouve très
bientôt pour le prochain chronique de
profs qui sortira en septembre sur moi
au début
voilà à bientôt revoir
[Musique]